ich liebe es zu essen ich liebe es Essen
zu bestellen heute machen wir genau das
und zwar auch eine ganz bestimmte Art
und Weise wir haben uns überlegt nachdem
unser letztes Video ein bis fünf Sterne
Essen bestellen echt super gut bei euch
ankam und ihr großes Interesse daran
hattet haben uns die Kommentare
angeschaut ihr meint es macht das mal
mit einer Speise und wir werden das
jetzt wenn ihr Lust darauf habt mit
verschiedenen Speisen durchmachen Burger
Pizza die beliebtesten Speisen Eric
bestellt bei verschiedenen Restaurants
die gleiche Speise packt sie aus macht
sie ein bisschen unkenntlich wir gucken
uns das gemeinsam an gucken wie ist die
Zusammensetzung wie ist die Qualität
verteilen unsere Sterne Bewertung und am
Ende gucken wir gemeinsam ob wir richtig
liegen ich bin gespannt ob ihr die
gleichen Ideen haben werdet wie ich
fangen wir an mit der Bestellung also
Leute
[Gelächter]
das heutige Gericht was wir bestellen
werden ist Pizza und wir suchen jetzt
von jedem Stern eine Pizza aus ich werde
darauf achten nichts zu bestellen was
Max schon kennt um es ihm möglichst
schwer zu machen wir machen es diesmal
komplett unerkenntlich so wie Max auch
gesagt hat und wir bestellen jetzt
okay die erste Pizza ist angekommen okay
sieht erstmal ganz normal aus ne
das könnte jetzt auch so Pizza haben
sein mag es Augen zu bitte ja du siehst
super aus
herausfinden bist du aufgeregt ich bin
so aufgeregt dass ich da noch eine
Gesichtsmaske gemacht habe
Salami Salami
okay Salami habe ich schon mal richtig
gerochen
erster Blick sieht aus so wie du sie
geschnitten hast sieht es aus wie so ein
klassisches Take Away Pizza Stück so
wurde in New York würde man das Pizza
nennen aber
okay der Boden hat wie sagt man tigerung
das sieht schon mal gut aus
es ist so Streukäse nicht so einzelne
gerissene Stücke Büffelmozzarella wie es
beispielsweise bei napoletanischer Pizza
ist die Salami Stücke sind alle so
gleichförmig so das sieht aus wie so
eine normale in Anführungszeichen Salami
also wir sind
vielleicht nicht am absolut oberen Ende
unterwegs aber die Pizza sieht durchaus
sehr solide aus hier am Rand das sieht
auch aus wie so samula also wieso
italienisches ich es ist Maismehl ja
weißt du das hier okay es sieht nicht
verkehrt aus ich glaube dadurch wie
dünnen Sie ausgearbeitet ist kann sie
auch nicht die Schlechteste sein ich
probiere einfach mal
das erinnert mich so sehr ich habe extra
Salami genommen weil bei einer Margarita
hätte man sonst zu wenig noch zum
unterscheiden so hat man noch eine
weitere Komponente die einen
Qualitätsunterschied geben kann ist auch
die Lieblingspizza der deutschen ne die
Pizza sagen wie viel Fußballfelder Pizza
essen wir
schmeckt sehr gut für mich das so eine
L'Osteria so ein riesen Pizza ja das ist
auch mein Kopf der mit der mir so eine
Falle stellt weißt du weil das kann ja
auch einfach wenn das Stück war ja so
groß ich weiß halt nicht mal wie viel
Sterne die erste Pizza hat ich weiß halt
nicht mal mit welchen Sternen bestellt
wurde also ob zwei drei vier bestellt
wurde
153 bestellt wurde wir werden auch in
Zukunft immer bei drei verschiedenen
Restaurants bestellen und ich weiß nicht
wie viel Sterne es sind also ich weiß
nicht ob wir bei einem ein
stern-restaurant bei einem drei Sterne
bei einem 5 Sterne Restaurant bestellen
oder vielleicht zwei drei vier
dementsprechend bin ich wirklich ein
bisschen auf dem Holzweg und muss mich
in die breite Masse hineindenken das
hier ist keineswegs eine schlechte Pizza
die
Crunch Tomatensoße ist nice Salamis nice
Käse ist okay 4 Sterne Pizza Nummer 2
ist da das so zwei Stücke dann einfach
nehmen Pizarro Nummer
rassistisch
und gleiche Stücke geschnitten
okay also ich habe gerade eben noch
gedacht vielleicht war das auch Vapiano
Pizza aber ich habe das Gefühl ich habe
diese Pizza so wie sie gerade war schon
mal gegessen und das ist so eine aus so
einem Systemgastronomie Unternehmen das
hier ist optisch schon mal nicht
konkurrenzfähig zu der die wir davor
hatten wir sehen hier so das ist
wahrscheinlich ist das einfach so ein
kurz gegangener Teig so wenn wir uns das
mal angucken der hat relativ wenige
Luftbläschen entwickelt und so der hat
hier so eine harte knackige Oberschicht
so weißt du aber so trotzdem die so
glatt also auch dass man so Oregano über
die Pizza macht das ist schon direkt auf
den ersten Blick eric hat mir versteckt
sich hinter der Softbox aber dieser
Gesicht nicht lesen kann das ist auf den
ersten Blick schon direkt eine Kategorie
drunter auf jeden Fall wir gucken mal
wie sie schmeckt also auf ordentlich
Käse drauf geladen
salzig weil er so viel Käse drauf ist
das Ding ist keine Pizza ist eigentlich
eine schlechte Pizza wie wird eine Pizza
schlecht wenn sie nicht ganz
durchgebacken ist also gib mir diese
Pizza um 3 Uhr nachts wenn ich so von so
einem feuchtfröhlichen Abend nach Hause
komme und es kann für mich eine richtig
geile Pizza sein im Vergleich mit der
anderen ist die definitiv unterlegen die
Zutaten haben nicht so eine hohe Quali
die ist weniger italienisch also das ist
so eine ich probiere noch mal den Rand
der Teig ist es auch einfach nicht also
der ist wahrscheinlich nicht lange
gegangen der ist ein bisschen trocken
daran man kann die 100% Essen die Pizza
aber das ist definitiv glaube ich die
schlechteste von den dreien ohne die
dritte gegessen zu haben ich glaube
schwenke zwischen zwei und drei Sterne
glaube diese Pizza hat zwei Sterne ich
esse erstmal die andere und dann gucke
ich ob das vielleicht mein ganzes Voting
durcheinander wirft aber dann bin ich
mir ein bisschen sicherer ich glaube
trotzdem dass es eher eine zwei Sterne
Pizza als eine drei Sterne Pizza weil
die sind nämlich genau die die auch
nachts liefern und dann brauchen wir 90
Minuten und dann regen sich Leute auf
und drücken eine schlechte Bewertung
weil die Pizza auch nicht so gut ist ja
zwei Sterne
also die letzte Pizza ist da diesmal
nicht geschnitten das heißt wir können
selber so ein schönes großes Stück
rausschneiden um Max ein bisschen in die
Verwirrung zu treiben so wie ich es
liebe
fühlt sich gar nicht gut an okay Bro
bist du ready
auch nicht die beste nein nee jetzt
geht's herauszufinden ob die von gerade
oder die schlechter ist weil die erste
ist meine Nummer eins das guck mal man
kann so viel wirklich mit dem ersten
Blick schon Aussagen guck mal das Ding
ist wir haben jetzt keine verschiedenen
Kategorien so also wir haben keine
napoletanische Pizza wir haben keine
deeptisch Pizza und so sondern die
spielen alle auf dem gleichen Spielfeld
so das sind alles so ein bisschen flache
oh guck mal
[Musik]
man hört keinen cruncher rausgeschnitten
wir haben auch Oregano obendrauf so
getrockneter Oregano ist auch nice auf
so einer Pizza aber das ist alles für
mich nichts was so der krasseste Laden
macht deshalb ist auch immer so zu sind
so zwei Phasen so Pizza den Belag nicht
geheiratet der die nicht angenommen also
vom Handling her man muss auch dazu
sagen was natürlich immer in so eine
Bewertung reinspielt ist die Lieferzeit
die beste wie ich finde kam als
allererstes kam super schnell zweite kam
kurz darauf dann nicht so gut qualitativ
aber schnell geliefert die hier ist
nicht so gut und hat lange gebraucht das
spricht bevor ich probiert habe jetzt
schon dafür dass die vielleicht noch mal
den Platz tauscht mit unserer Pizza
davor aber der Geschmackstest gucken uns
noch mal den Boden an der sieht
eigentlich super solid aus das hat
glaube ich bei einer napolitanischen
Pizza am meisten Aussagekraft ob da so
ein schönes so verkohltes Tigermuster
unten drauf ist probieren einfach genug
gelabert
du hast die vorher schon so runter
gemacht ich war vor sie schmeckt jetzt
geisteskrank
gleiche Sache wie gerade ein bisschen zu
salzig und ein bisschen viel Salz und
wahrscheinlich salziger Käse salzige
Mozzarella wenn das überhaupt Mozzarella
ist raus aus meinem Kopf Eric ich mache
das mit mir selbst aus also ich denke
ich beleidige niemanden durch meine
Bewertung weil ich habe es ja jetzt
eigentlich alles gut begründet oder hier
fehlt komplett der Crunch das kann sein
Thomas kann sein dass die Pizza
eigentlich super gut ist die haben sich
Verfahren ich weiß wirklich von nichts
weil in quasi isoliert von der auswählt
nämlich Verfahren eigentlich super
dadurch ist die so sorry geworden im
Karton die ist aber du hast nicht zwei
von einer Bewertung bestellt ne das geht
nicht okay an der Teig ist nicht
besonders
[Musik]
ist nicht so gut aber trotzdem auch hier
wieder wenn ich so nach dem Feiern gehen
an der Pizzeria vorbeilaufen die die
Pizza verkauft so her damit so ich nehme
die so frisch aus dem Ofen nicht
geliefert ist das noch mal ein anderes
Ding diese Pizza hat zwei Sterne diese
Pizza hier hat zwei Sterne hier sind sie
unsere drei Pizzen und wenn ich sie so
vor mir sehe dann finde ich die erste
wie es auch direkt gesagt habe am
hübschesten also es ist eine super
solide Pizza der Rand ist knusprig
Tomatensoße schmeckt Salami fein
käsefein es ist keine fünf von fünf es
ist meine vier von fünf deine vier von
fünf die reale Bewertung dieser Pizza
ist zwei Sterne
[Musik]
die wurde schnell geliefert die schmeckt
gut die ist zwei von fünf Sternen hat
diese Pizza es macht wirklich gar keinen
Sinn für mich das macht wirklich keinen
Sinn ich weiß nicht ob die die Leute
angespuckt haben als sie die Pizza
ausgeliefert haben oder 2,8 Sterne bei
502 Bewertungen es ist mehr an drei
Sterne aber trotzdem macht es für mich
wenig Sinn zumal ich ja jetzt weiß dass
die anderen Pizzen darüber angesiedelt
sein müssen weil es gibt quasi kein
Restaurants mit einem Stern check ich
nicht was für Laden ist es Vapiano
L'Osteria L'Osteria du hast schon mal
richtig gesagt bis dann das war auf
Vapiano rüber gegangen und dann war es
doch der erste call du hast es richtig
erkannt aber es war doch viel schwerer
jetzt schon ohne die Verpackung zu sehen
und so weiter oder es war viel schwerer
viel schwerer aber Leute wenn man jetzt
so jemand fragt was für ein Laden ist
lasteria für dich Leute wenn sagen vier
von fünf Jahren oh okay super solide
aber ich verstehe die Welt nicht mehr
dann hat die zweite Pizza die zunächst
mit zwei Sternen bewertet hatte ich
hoffe ihr könnt Urteil nachvollziehen so
weil ihr das seht hier die hat ja diesen
super glatten Rand und so die hier hat
so eine schöne Farbe am Rand das sieht
alles ein bisschen komisch aus da
brauchst Du dabei was ich gegeben hätte
diese Pizza hat drei Sterne du sagst
drei Sterne diese Pizza von Pizza
Colonia hat 4,8 von
4.355 Bewertungen
also es macht wirklich keinen Sinn ich
hoffe dass die Zuschauer das Verstehen
ne dass die nicht so sagen ich bin
komplett verwirrt aber ich habe ja schon
viel gute Pizza gegessen ich habe selbst
viel Pizza gemacht wir waren beim
Weltmeister so er hat das Gefühl ich
muss mich erklären dass ich da so
daneben lag aber ja es ist einfach
scheinbar nicht meine Pizza aber
vielleicht ist es der Geschmack von
vielen anderen Leuten also ich würde
immer diese Pizza statt dieser hier
wählen no Front an den Laden ich habe ja
zu jeder Pizza gesagt jede Pizza kann
geil sein aber das verstehe ich nicht
kommen wir damit zur letzten Pizza und
jetzt bin ich wirklich verwirrt der
Pizza habe ich zwei Sterne gegeben in
der Realität hat aber die Pizza zwei
Sterne deshalb hat diese Pizza
wahrscheinlich irgendeine für mich
ungerechtfertigt hohe Bewertung die
letzte Pizza von heute von piccola to go
Agnesviertel das ist piccola hat 3,7
Sterne bei 67 Bewertungen ich kenne
piccola piccola Pizza mag ich auch
eigentlich gerne aber das ist also
no Front so man kann das lieferkonzept
glaube ich optimieren weil du kannst
wirklich suchen du findest keinen Crunch
bei der Pizza also wirklich das ist
verrückt also ich hätte nicht gedacht
dass wir so ein Ergebnis bekommen können
bei diesem Video vielleicht könnt ihr
mich nachvollziehen vielleicht sagt ihr
auch ich wurde vorgeführt aber
nichtsdestotrotz eine sehr interessante
Erfahrung und ich glaube es ist
wahnsinnig interessant gewesen für mich
und hoffentlich auch für euch wir werden
das ganze machen mit allen beliebten
Gerichten die man sich so vorstellen
kann ihr könnt über das nächste
entscheiden schreibt einfach mal einen
Kommentar rein was ich mir persönlich
hier von wegnehmen kann ist guckt
einfach nicht genau auf die Sterne weil
vielleicht ist euer persönlicher
Geschmack abseits dem der anderen ich
würde sagen Leute auf diesem Pizzakarton
hier ist ein für euch vorgeschlagenes
Video da könnt ihr einfach draufklicken
das ist nur für euch und abonniert gerne
Kanal wenn euch das Video gefallen hat
wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder
ciao ciao
[Musik]